the next talk is from alejandro who will
tell us
about classification taking into account
that not all
faults are as bad as the others i think
so yeah go all right
so hello everyone
i'm alejandro correa i'm from the
university of luxembourg
currently i'm finishing my phd there
the first thing that you can note is
that i change a bit the title of the
presentation
and the main reason for that is that
once i finish the slides with the
previous title
i realized quite quickly that it was
very boring so
this is my second attempt and i think it
will be
much better so it's called example
dependent code sensitive
create scoring using um
before i begin i think it's
important to give babiru a bit of a
background about me
so as i said this is my last year
doing my phd actually my last month at
luxembourg university in particular the
topic of my phd has been
what i'm going to present right now so
call sensitive classification
um quite cool i work part-time as a
fraud data scientist
whatever that means at etc a card
processing company in luxembourg
and so in so i say it's cool because i
spent part time working at the
at the credit card company part time at
the university but it's actually the
same project
so it's the same long-term project doing
very applied research and before i
started that i worked for five years as
a data scientist
back in colombia first at g money then
on scotia bank
i also spent a couple of years at dow
chemical
mostly used doing six sigma projects
my academic background i did my bachelor
in industrial engineering and my
mastering financial engineering
on my free time i organized the data
science luxembourg meetup
of this has been running for almost
three years
and yeah a couple months ago we started
running the
the big data science bogota meetup
okay so this is the agenda
so today or this is what i'm going to
talk about
um a very quick introduction to create a
scoring i
promise this is not going to be boring
then our example of how to
solve a create a scoring problem using
python
then i will go into the interesting part
that is how you should evaluate to
create a scorecard
and finally at the end i'm going to
present quite quickly the library that i
create okay so create
great scoring let's start in a different
way
so this is let's suppose
that you are a bank and you are going to
issue
a loan and you have these two guys that
arrive
so the first guy just created just
funded an investment bank
and the other one just quick college to
whom you will give the
the loan to the banker who will give a
loan to a bunker i think that's a
no-brainer
uh this is the problem of giving this
light on this
uh on this kind to these audience
so i assume everyone will give the loan
to a guy that quick college right
so yeah so
then you have that the banker end up
creating the biggest
ponzi scheme ever perpetrated in the u.s
actually in the world and the other one
was having new year
but it's very easy to judge that after
the fact right yeah
if today you will receive someone asking
you for
money let's say on a peer-to-peer
lending platform
and one is working in has a high
position in a bank and the other one
just quick college then you will have a
different
idea all right so
create scoring you want to mitigate the
impact of credit risk
in order to make more objective and
accurate decisions
in particular you want to estimate the
risk of a customer defaulting
a a contracted financial obligation
using past
experience there has been a bunch of
machine learning methods that have been
applied to the
to solve this problem and in the
literature you find low distribution
neural networks so on and so forth
in practice you only find logistic
regressions mostly because of regulatory
issues but
the typical answers are as well
interpretability of the models and
implementation of the model so on and so
forth
in a big more technical way a creator's
a creative scorecard you want to
calculate the probability
of a customer i defaulting his loan here
i'm representing the defaulting of alone
by the class label as the positive
example so
y equals 1 given x what is
x it will be demographic information of
the customer
historical information of previous
loans that the customer has has
the usage of the credit cards and other
things
so now let's go to an example i think
this is
better so using a cable crate uh
data set that was from around 2011
um so there was a competition on cable
on using a create a scorecard data set
construct a classification model in
order to predict
that somewhere someone with us will
experience some financial distress
in the next two years the reason i use
this data set is because
it contains nice good information
about the features usually order
create scorecard data sets only say x1
x2 x3 so on
here there is some information about the
features that as i will show later is
quite important for my analysis
um okay so you load
this data set um using a a various
small script that i have on on this
library the information that you have on
this data set is enough for you to
understand the data so you have
where are the which is the target where
the name description
is a long description where are the
features where the data
in particular the data has around 110
000 customers on
the label so
from those uh a hundred and twelve
thousand customers
only seven thousand six hundred are
defaulted
uh they're also called as bad customers
and this is quite interesting because
this makes this problem
an imbalanced problem it's not that
imbalanced but nevertheless only six
percent six point seven percent of the
population
uh are positive or bark customers
um
the features that this data has so okay
so you have the age
you have the mo the monthly income which
actually reflects that this data set is
not from the us because in the us you
cannot
use that feature then you have um
historical information about the
customer so the number of uh
so the utilization of the crea of the
crate of the credit cards
then you have how many times in the past
he has been in financial distress
some information about that
so created scoring is a classification
problem i want to predict
which customers are going are going
which of
uh use information about historical
customers i want to predict
which new customers are going to be bad
customers
and then make a simple decision and
don't give money to those customers
um so i first split the data set in
training and testing
very straightforward then
i train some algorithms that i randomly
choose
random forest registration and decision
tree
the very very easy way to train it i'm
using
kill learn there is not nothing
fairly interesting here
then i evaluate the results so how you
will
going to evaluate the results of one of
these models so
you are going to say okay i want to see
the accuracy of the model i want to see
the
f1 square of the model precision recall
and you may say the
they are under the q5 score but in this
case we want to
actually evaluate the final
classification so let's stick
with these ones and then you get a
figure like this
the figure is ugly on purpose so
first we analyze the accuracy and if you
as i tell before this is an imbalance
problem
so the issue with that is that a naive
algorithm that predicts that there are
no positive examples
is going to have a very good accuracy so
in general acuras is not going to tell
us
anything in the for this kind of
problems so then we see the
the precision the recall or the hour the
weighted average of the two
the f1 score so that's a bit better
so using that information i will say
okay decision tree is my
best model it has 24 at
0.24 of f1 score um
and that's it you finish you create a
scar card you go you
if you're a consultant you go and give
the final result
if you're working as a data scientist in
a bank you will
implement that model but the issue is
that
these measures are not actually taking
into account the business and common
economic
realities that take place in greater
scoring so these measures are
saying some information about the
evaluation of a classification model but
are not specific
in any sense to this particular problem
and in general the cost
that the financial institution has to
incur in order to acquire customers
is by all means not included in in
in any of this feature in any of these
measures
um on the other hand you have the
expected profit data
a particular client or customer will
generate
so this is of course quite important
because you can say
that if i decline a customer if i have a
misclassification
on two customers and both are expected
to be
good customers but the model
misclassified them as bad customers so i
would not give money to them
but these two customers one has a very
long
is requesting a very long maybe a
corporate
credit card and the other one is me so a
small credit card
so of course miss classif misclassifying
the other guy have a very different
financial impact
and there is something that we are not
seeing in the current evaluation
measures
so that was the motivation
so let's evaluate from a financial point
of view the outcome
of this classification model so
again the motivation
created scorecard models are evaluated
using traditional
or standard cost insensitive measures
however in practice the cost associated
with
approving a bad customer
is not the same as the cost associated
with declining a good customer
and furthermore at the example that i
gave not all the customers
will generate me the same profit so i
have
two very important issues here and the
way
that uh the way that uh that this is
solved
is by using a cost matrix so uh
this is familiar to a confusion matrix
in the sense that i have
what the model is predicting so either
is the model predicted positive or
negative
and on the other side i have what is the
actual or the grand true
if it is actually a good cons about
customer
or a good customer um i'm not going to
go
that deep into that but
after some a couple months on doing
research and
actually talking with some banks we
arrive to this course matrix
in very general we assume that there is
no cost
when you correctly classify someone so
this diagonal is zero
but when you have a false positive
meaning you decline a customer
that then will become a good you first
are losing
the profit that that customer will
generate then you have an
er another cost that that is related to
the fact that you are not going to
keep that money idle but you are going
to use that money to
another to give to someone else on the
on the worst case you have a false
negative so false negative is
when you approve a customer but then
that customer default
so in a very simplistic way
you are going to lose the amount that
you give the customer
times the loss giving default and this
loss giving default
is related to the fact what that when a
customer stop
paying sometimes you are going to arrive
to have some kind of agreement so you
are going to say
only pay me the half and that's it or
things like that so you don't usually
lose
all the amount but a percentage
actually i already see that if you want
to go to actually
use this or or or under some more this
here is the link or i will be happy to
have that discussion later
but i will stop here because it's
actually a very long discussion and very
interesting by the way
um so how i create that cost matrix for
the
um for for the kegel data set so
in this in the cargo data site there is
some information about
the income of the customer with the
current debt of the customer
that will allow me to infer what is the
disposable amount of the cost
of the customer then there was some
information about
you more or less can infer that it was
an average european bank so you could
make a huge assumption assumption and
estimate what is the
the interest rate that you are going to
uh to charge
what is the cost of funds and loss
giving default for hours in europe
and some some information that you need
in order to calculate this particular
model
um on the data set that i already have
that i already have this information is
already calculated
nevertheless if you can use also a
library if you want to change any of
these parameters
so now but the thing is that okay so now
i have the cost matrix
that is giving me what is my expected
loss when i make a mix classification
for each customer
but i would like to know the overall
results of our models
so what i what i did is that first i
calculate what is the cost of the model
nothing other than the estimatory of the
individual cost matrix for each customer
in the sense that every time i make a
wrong a false negative
i assume that number every time i make a
false positive i sum that number
however the total cost is normally not
that easy to interpret so a better way
to interpret it is a savings
and the savings are defined as the cost
that your model has
compared with the cost of using no model
meaning of the naive model that is going
to predict that there are no positives
so that's a very simple way to
to evaluate the savings
so this is already included in the
in the library so it's a very easy
function
calculate the savings is actually making
the summative internally
you have the true label what is the
prediction
and the cost matrix that's of course is
important and here is the code it's
fairly easy
so what are the results for for the
previous models that we calculate
so now we see that random forest is
having a savings of
12 percent though this regulation is not
working at all in this particular data
set
and decision tree has a savings of 17
i'm comparing here only against the f1
square i don't want to
put too much information there so what
is interesting here is that
okay now we have a measure to say
what are the actual financial impact of
the model
you are able to compare it with other
measures and
a general conclusion that i have in all
my talks and in
all my papers is that when you compare
the model by using the
f1 score or the savings in general you
are going to have
different results and is the first
conclusion in all my papers
we i always found something like that
so as i was saying there is some
differences when
in the results when evaluating models
using this
call sensitive measures but or by using
a standard cost in sensitivity measures
now something interesting 17 percent of
savings is actually very bad
so when you go to sell the model with a
25 f1 score
okay the gun the in jail very general
the guy that is receiving the model
is going to say thank you but when you
go to save the model with a 70
of savings if you are at the data
scientist in the bank
they quite easily calculate what is the
cost
that that you have and is that higher
than 17
well that is difficult to calculate it
may be but
um but the other thing is that you mean
you may say okay you are doing a
unfair comparison you are using models
that are
training in order to in in a very
simplistic way to minimize the
misclassification
and you are going to evaluate those
models with
a financial measure that was not
introduced
at any point before during the training
so
one way to to deal with that is by using
um what i call example dependent cause
sensitive classification
very important first why example
dependent
so when you talk about cause sensitive
classification
in the machine learning in more general
data mining
literature you are going to find out
that that is referring to
the class uh to class dependent cost
so co-sensitive is usually means that
you have a different cost between the
false positive
and false negative and the reason i make
the distinction
example dependent is because i'm not
assuming that the cost that
that different in cost is constant i'm
saying
that cost is going to depend by each
customer in the case of create created
scoring
so as i said before in greater scoring
different customers
have different credit lines which
implies
that the costs are not constant
so this is a model it's the only one i'm
going to
explain today so one way to
make a classifier call sensitive is by
using a little bit of decision theory
and
calculating what are the expected losses
when i make
a positive or a negative prediction so
in particular when i predict that
something
that some in the case of greatest
growing when i predict that
someone is not is a good customer
then i can use the expected probability
and weighted by the cost of that
particular decision
and then on the other way around when i
predict when i
want to calculate the cost of predicting
someone
as positive i do the same i use the
estimated probability by any model i
multiply it by the expected
the expected cost and now i have a
measure to say
okay if the risk of predicting positive
is higher than the risk of creating
negative then
your prediction should be negative okay
so it's
a fairly simple concept uh taking from
decision theory
uh that has quite interesting
interesting results
and so of course this model is included
in the in the library
um i like to say that the documentation
is good enough
so you have the fit function very
similar to cycle learn
of course including some additional
parameters that are needed for training
the code for this particular for the
cable example
you just call the base minimum risk
classifiers
uh there is one function for fitting one
good function for making the prediction
and that's it
then we evaluate uh so
i make the comparison of the three
models i mean
the logistic relation the random forest
and the decision trees
and then each one combining with the by
with the base minimum risk
and what is found is quite interested
first
overall there is an increase in savings
from 17 percent
to 42. so it's very very very
significant
the actual financial difference then
more specifically logistic regression
increase
quite significantly and the reason for
that is that
as this model is using the estimated
probabilities though this relation does
a very good job
estimating the actual probability so
that's why that model increase
the results quite a lot on the decision
trees on the other hand the argument
will be
more or less the same one the decision
trees in general
is not a very good model for estimating
probabilities so this model
does not perform that well when using
with a decision tree
um so on
on the side of the f1 score we sound we
find interesting things
for example decision tree and the low
distribution with base minimum risk
have let's say the same savings but a
completely different
f1 score so this is as i say one of the
conclusions that i'd like to carry
around
i'm going to show the results of two
other models but i'm not going
i'm not going to go that deep into that
say why
so the best minimum risk increase the
savings
however is only introducing the cost
after the algorithm was trained
so why not train the algorithm to
actually go and minimize internally they
say
uh a proxy of the savings so i did that
with two models one is called
call sensitive decision trees the other
one is a
symbol of cause sensitive decision trees
in particular i use random patches
which is fairly similar to random forest
again very simplistic way to say it
and both are already implemented so it's
just a function
and the way to call it is as inside kill
learn you just need to include the new
parameter that is the cost matrix
that the algorithm is needed in order to
be able to make the prediction
so result wise these
two new models increase for their
designs now we are talking about
almost 50 percent of cybings actually a
bit more in the last one
f1 score increase as well and there is
uh increasing complexity by using
these the constantly the random patches
at the end is an ensemble of a lot of
these ones
and even though the increase in savings
is not that much
um this model i have found in my paper
that is more robust
so that is why i still leave it there
but for this one example without
cross validation or anything is giving a
better results
so what i have talked about so far
so again selective model based on
traditional
statistics does not give the same result
in terms of savings
and the simple explanation is that those
statistics are not trying to take into
account the financial service
and are not created in that sense so
it's wrong
to take off uh to assume that
the maximization of a cost incentive
statistic
is actually trying to maximize the
profit or the financial income of
uh of the business that is using the
model
moreover models should be evaluated
taking into account
the real financial cost of the
applications
algorithms should be developed to
incorporate
those financial costs um so now the last
part of the presentation i'm going to
talk very quickly about the library
so the library is built on top of jackie
learn pandas and numpy
as expected there is a bunch of
different algorithms in particular of
course the one i
did through my psg but there are there
are some others
there are some data sets so so there is
already some dataset with some
with the cost matrix already calculated
so i think that's a very important
contribution
because one of the issue in the research
in this field
of code sensitive clarification is that
there are not
good enough data sets that actually you
have all the financial information
no this is not the this is not an issue
in a company i mean
in a bank all the data set you could
include all the financial information
associated with each particular loan
so in industry you will find that you
have all that information
but on the academic data set that you
find around in uci
or so on you you don't have that
information
there is a lot of future work and there
is an
i the need for speeding up all the
actually all the algorithms
i did not include so far the class
dependent algorithms
i know there are some implementations
around i have used some but there is a
need for
i think would be interesting to put
everything together and
there are more things to do
okay so that was my presentation thank
you
okay so we do have some time for
questions so questions anyone
so thanks for that talk that was very
interesting so
during the panel earlier on i think
someone mentioned about
the business case and the costs you know
of
implementing something so do you feel
that kind of fits into that
kind of making data science business
friendly and
you know managing expectations and stuff
like that do you feel that this is
a very important contribution to that
kind of area
um okay so uh thank you for the question
i will say that as i work part-time
in in a credit card company um and i
used to work beca
before in a bank i have to make two
presentations every time i'm making
i'm going to present a model the
presentation for the
university and the presentation for the
bank and the presentation for the bank
only have one slide
what are the financial savings and
that's straightforward they understand
that and they know how to fight against
that the university one has
okay whatever measure or everything that
you
need to have i'm not saying you don't
need to have it but
in some sense that allows to have a very
easy conversation between the academic
and the industry
and extrapolating to your question
of course from a consulting point of
view it is
way more easier when you are going to if
you sell the model
of the financial saving that is going to
have the model other than the
reduction of mis-classification yup
um thank you for the talk as well i also
thought it was very interesting
so um i have a question so
as i understand you included the cost
for each individual loan do you think
the model can be extended to also
include the possible profit for every
loan so that you
uh have a look at the costs as well as
the profits
yes for sure you might say that you can
model
a cost matrix as a profit matrix and
in general i would expect to have
similar results in the sense that
you can model what are the expecting
profit of
each customer and then the
the cost matrix more or less invert you
know so
so of course um or you can have
uh in general uh um
yeah profitability metrics so you put
all not only the cost
also where the the financial profit that
each customer will generate
um is is actually up to you
more important up to which information
you have
and sometimes it's easier to find to
model the profit than the expected
losses
okay thanks
so this is the last question i think so
thanks for the talk really interesting
um
one question why why you didn't try to
include this code in
psyclearn for example okay so
third question i when i start doing
this actually sorry for
for the very unpopular comment i start
on fighting because my advisor told me
to start on python and that was
three years ago uh so it was not until
recently that i feel that this code
is let's say good enough for something
like that
um that is that will be of course
something quite interesting in order to
give more continuation to the project in
general
and i definitely will try to do
something like that
thanks okay unless there are any
very urgent questions i would propose
that we thank the speaker again
thank you